and we got a good super super chat that
makes a great example a great analogy
a a battle is being fought but but
between two ideological opponents one
side continually insists if we have The
High Ground we must seed to the lower
ground an evil battle even Battlefield
with our enemies it's only fair and the
right thing to do and they say thank you
and then they start shooting at you
again yeah so it's like dude take The
High Ground I'm done with I'm done with
this if people want free speech to
navigate for free speech and have
disparate opinions and and anger
opinions and bad opinions and leftist
opinions I don't care if Elon Musk ban
someone literally because they were
making fun of him I'd be like that is BS
but these are people who are lying the
media is lying they're claiming they
were banned for making fun of Elon Musk
total lies they're saying they filed the
rules total lies they are setting fire
to the system and hoping we give them an
opportunity to come back I'm not doing
it